je comprends pas que laurent wauquiez
veulent pas d'un débat télévisé parce
que quand on veut se mesurer à manuel
macron c'est un peu ce qui fait dans le
journal du dimanche de ce week-end on
peut pas refuser des débats télévisés
donc je comprends pas je pense que il
n'a pas du tout conscience de ses
intérêts en plus je pense que c'est
quelqu'un qui peut être un bon débatteur
donc je ne comprends pas je pense c'est
une sorte de refus d'obstacle et par
rapport à ce que vous disiez sur les
jeunes pourront évidemment c'est bien
bon après je pense que le sujet c'est
que moi je pense que vous qui va gagner
enfin ça me semble acquis il faut quand
même le dire aujourd'hui je pense qu'il
est il est de loin sans doute le
meilleur chef des républicains qui va
être potentiellement donc en revanche je
ne comprends pas leur attitude vis-à-vis
dé constructif c'est à dire que les
constructifs ils sont eux-mêmes en
difficulté ils n'ont pas de ligne sauf
de koléa macron et ils en font ils en
font quelque chose d'important comme un
bout de sparadrap du capitaine haddock
moi je trouve que laurent wauquiez là il
a une espèce d'inhibition peut-être
parce qu'il va devenir chef du parti
mais il faut évidemment qu'il fasse un
débat télévisé il faut qu'il y ait non
pas qu'ils excluent le constructif
l'avait dominé à manquer de fermeté
voilà deux ans c'est pareil big ben a
très bien fait le sujet c'est plutôt de
reconnaître qu'ils sont déjà partis
enfin vous savez les exclusions
aujourd'hui quand les parties exclu
c'est un aveu de faiblesse donc faire un
feuilleton d'exclusion c'est un double
aveu de faiblesse
quand le ps voulait exclure des gens moi
j'ai gelé vécu parce que j'ai été au
parti socialiste j'étais parti de longue
date ils ont essayé de m'exclure mais
j'étais parti donc le sujet c'est qu'on
exclut plus personne dans les partis
aujourd'hui on est déjà parti et on
reconnaît qu il sont partis c'est tout
et puis on leur souhaite bon vent et
puis on fait sa ligne politique et puis
on fait un débat à la télévision